times journalist aaron aubry kaplan who
is black describes building a little
free library box in her front yard cute
right creating a self-operated community
exchange of books for neighbors and
visitors and the occasional woodpecker
and it all seemed to be going perfectly
until a young white couple was spotted
browsing the little library kaplan says
the experience filled her with
astonishment and resentment quote what i
resented was not the specific couple it
was their whiteness and my feelings of
helplessness at not knowing how to
maintain the integrity of a black space
that i had created end quote
sorry the library was my lawn but for
that moment it became theirs but isn't
that the whole point of a library not
that i know i haven't been to a library
since the incident in the periodicals
section
i cleaned up after
the author was able to link this evil
white couple to jim crow laws and
burning crosses all for looking at the
books that she set out presumably for
everyone to look at except of course
whitey and that naturally got in the
times just grab any topic even a tiny
library and link it to racism and it
pays then again maybe she's on to
something maybe we need more specific
libraries
[Music]
hi i'd like to check out some free books
short guys
oh
ooh uh hi i'd like to check out some
free
no comedians
uh oh
no italians oh come on this is the
italian elimination sure i am sorry i
ran out of ink
well in that case mamma mia
[Applause]
oh my god that was danny devito
uh cat uh next time why not just do a
bird feeder just for black birds
[Laughter]
might be hard to enforce that
uh i don't know i don't know i mean
assuming that this actually happened yes
which i'm not sure it actually happened
like
imagine because imagine being the couple
and reading like if you're out there hit
me up i'd love to know how you feel yeah
he was writing about like just feeling
so horrible which like look i'm a white
person right like probably what happened
is
the woman was like that's cute and the
guy was like yeah all right babe let's
go and that was it yes exactly
so assuming this is real i wonder they
feel but i'm not so sure it's real yeah
you're a white person of color no i'm
white yes you are look at me
tyrus maybe it would have helped if she
put blacks only on the library
what
why are you looking at me that way
we're short on time you know
i would just like to say yes
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
some of us are
stupid
[Applause]
that's it are bad
[Laughter]
read away whitey yes
sorry
you know um i think greg that i whenever
i see these little free libraries they
just oh the books are never any good you
they're like you're trying to unload
crappy books
and i mean that all people not just
specific groups well my crappy library
that i have at the at the end of my
driveway um is is actually quite a nice
little library um it did you know it
degenerates over time when people take
books but you do this yeah i have a
little library you make me sick
[Laughter]
it's a britishness it's a beautiful it
is a beautiful sound yes to hear the
kids stop and get excited and we i don't
care what color they are what do you do
like we should be encouraging children
to read books i just imagine the
editorial process for you know deciding
to run that kind of piece that
conversation like how did you have that
conversation yeah because everyone was
too scared to say it's not good because
they don't want to get called racist
that's right yeah but that had the
perfect you could take if you take
column one any subject and column b
racism sexism and put it together you
will be published in the new york times
gave me a great idea for framing
somebody for murder
somebody to death with a book and then
put the book in your book in the free
library
and then some homeless guy will pick up
the book
charged with murder actually the one
point i was going to make
my father my father would say
only perverts and weirdos give away free
stuff in their front yard
[Applause]
on your lawn
on your grass just work so hard to
manicure just to be clear after that
scurrilous
it's
at the end of my yard
wow okay no giving no giving this
christmas oh you can be wow okay
brutal
oh dagging down
on that note
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else